Pope Francis has opened an unprecedented
summit on sexual abuse in the Catholic
Church with bishops from around the
world
Francis opened the four-day meeting by
insisting that the church must listen to
abuse victims but survivors have voiced
concerns that the Pope's efforts to
raise awareness do not go far enough the
summit comes after an avalanche of
allegations against Catholic priests
accusing them of molesting young boys
and raping nuns let's listen now to more
of what Pope Francis had to say the holy
people of God are looking at us and do
not expect from us simple and
predictable condemn nations but concrete
and effective measures let's get more
now we are joined by DW religious
affairs analyst Martin gak how big is
this for the church Martin it's quite
big at least it is trumpeted as being
quite a sort of moment of you know
change in the church this is something
that remains to be seen however it is
true that there is a very clear the man
of concrete actions it is also true that
the church in 20 years is actually not
produced concrete actions do you see the
potential for that concrete action
because I mean many are looking at
they're saying oh great you know they're
talking about it now but can we see
something bigger come out of it than
just acknowledging that there is indeed
a problem I think that we should
disabuse ourselves from continuing this
talk about talking about it I mean the
church has been talking about and has
been talking about it for 20 years
victims have been talking about it NGOs
have been talking about it the church is
quite simply it has not produced
protocol or policy so it's unclear
whether they have the capacity to do it
and there is the political will the fact
is that there's been a couple of things
over the last two weeks including
mckarrick the fracking this very very
senior New York former Cardinal which
seemed to show that this Vatican
actually has the political wheel what we
don't know is where they have actually
the political muscle they have the
capacity to implement changes so let's
talk a little bit more about the
strategy because I mean they wrote the
following about how they plan to
approach this responsibility
accountability transparency are the
words that they're using I mean they say
that these three principles that it will
guide their strategy when there
talking about sex abuse in the church
what do you make of that well I think
that these are key words for any process
of adjudication you know I mean clearly
responsibility transparency and
accountability are important things I
think that what is telling about the
fact that these are actually headlining
topics is that the church understands
that it has lost legitimacy in all three
areas I mean the church is not seen as
something that is transparent it's not
seen as something that is responsible
and most certainly it's not seen as
something that is accountable to justice
in general so one of the I think most
important questions is whether the
church is willing to bring in national
authorities to adjudicate what are
actually crimes okay and do you think
that there's first of all the potential
for that I think that there is a
potential but I think that what you also
have is that in a very very large
institution with very many people any
one of these cases that you pull out has
a lot of people attached to it not only
people that necessarily raped or that
abuse but people that actually cover up
and people that might not have willingly
covered up but were part of systems so
what we're talking about here it's about
something that is truly truly widespread
and truly truly massive in terms of the
connections and the amount of political
and institutional relations I do not see
you know just a will to change as being
sufficient this is something that would
depend not only on the Vatican but it
also will depend off the churches at
local level across across over the world
really
DW religious affairs correspondent
Martin GAC thank you you're welcome
you